today on the matt walsh show the d.a in
kenosha has announced that the officers
involved the jacob blake shooting will
not be charged with a crime
the left is outraged about this of
course but i think the real outrage is
that jacob blake himself will also
not be charged with a crime even though
he committed many of them we'll talk
about that today also five headlines
including
the runoff election in georgia democrats
now stand poised to
take full control of the government but
who is to blame for the massive
republican failure in the state the
blame game
it's inevitable uh we'll get into that
today and a new study suggests that
maybe
it turns out men who identify as women
still have an advantage over women in
sports that's what the study suggests
anyway shocking stuff and in our daily
cancellation i will cancel
three bands who have declined their
grammy nomination saying they don't
deserve the nominations because they're
white
white guilt is a mental illness i
believe and i'll explain why all of that
and more today on the matt wall show
[Music]
[Applause]
so before we get going today i want to
tell you about uh our good friends over
at charity mobile
uh you know i'm talking about charity
mobile all the time mainly because i i
think it's such a win
it's the ultimate quintessential win-win
situation when you can
give business to a company that provides
valuable service good good service
um and a company that supports your
values at the same time
because that's that we know as
conservatives that is not something we
can take for granted
these days to say the least and there
are many companies out there many that
we give our money to every single day
that are working against us in the
culture um
but that's not the case with charity
mobile charity mobile the pro-life phone
company for good reason
five percent of your monthly plan price
with charity mobile goes to the pro-life
pro family charity of your choice
new activations and eligible accounts
get a free cell phone with free
activation and free shipping
so that's that's just one of the perks
you get also look there's no contract
there's no termination fees you also get
a 30-day
guarantee so there's no risk involved in
trying out charity mobile
and i guarantee you if you try charity
mobile you're going to want to stick
with them they also got live customer
service based in the usa so if you have
a problem you can always call them up
and i think the mate the headline though
again goes back to
helping to build a culture of life in
america while supporting a pro-life
phone company
you could turn everyday living into
effortless giving for the charity of
your choice i have my charitable
mobile phone right here it's a service
that i use and
the other thing is i've never had any
kinds of problems i get great signal
everywhere that i
am which is not which has not been my
experience historically with cell phones
but it is the case here so call charity
mobile at 1-877-474-3662
or chat with them online at
charitymobile.com
well big news out of georgia big news
happening in dc today big news
everywhere it seems
we'll talk about all that on the show
today but i want to start with events
out in kenosha wisconsin
i leave the show with kenosha for the
simple reason that in my view
the truth matters it really matters
perhaps now more than ever
and yesterday some important truth was
revealed or maybe we should say
confirmed
by the d.a in kenosha now you may recall
weeks of
rioting how could you forget uh in that
city over the summer in response to the
police shooting of jacob blake
this was one of the major catalysts for
rioting across the nation
what kept it going all summer after the
george floyd shooting kicked things off
jacob blake was memorialized even though
he's still alive by the way
by the nba many other professional uh
sports teams high-ranking democrats
including joe biden
made pilgrimages to the city to pay
homage to blake's family and blake
himself
and this was all done based on a
narrative that formed and cemented into
the public consciousness
within minutes of the original incident
the narrative if
you remember was this blake was driving
along on
the road one fine sunday with his kids
in the car you know probably taking them
to the park or to chuck e cheese or
something
minding his own business when he saw two
people
fighting and being such a good samaritan
blake pulled over to break up the fight
because he just cares so much about his
community and soon the cops showed up
assaulted poor mr blake and as he tried
to climb back into his vehicle with his
kids
they shot him in the back seven times
while unarmed for no reason
other than their own bigoted bloodlust
that was the tale that was told based on
a 30-second
out-of-context video and it was enough
to supposedly justify
all of the writing looting and murder
that came after it
but it was all a lie every part of it
every part of it
blake in fact was at the house because
he was harassing his ex-girlfriend the
same ex-girlfriend who had credibly
accused blake of breaking into her house
and raping her
a few months prior there was a felony
warrant out for blake's arrest because
of that
blake was not unarmed he actually had a
knife he assaulted the cops not the
other way around
and the car he was trying to climb into
was not his own he was attempting to
steal
it so this was a wanted criminal
a violent felon an accused rapist armed
with a knife
resisting arrest assaulting the cops
harassing his alleged rape victim and
trying to steal her car with their
children inside of it
that was enough already you know and and
and we knew all of that it was already
enough to just to
to know that the shooting was entirely
justified and blake
who is a scumbag of the highest order
brought everything on himself but
yesterday finally this reality was
confirmed by the kenosha d.a michael
gravely
who announced that there would be no
charges filed against the officers in
the case
it shouldn't have taken this long to
make this announcement it was as i said
obvious to any rational person within
the first day
that the officers did nothing wrong
nonetheless the right decision is being
made at least
the right decision with respect to the
officers there is a miscarriage of
justice here an outrage
worth talking about but we'll get to
that in a second first in explaining why
the officers
uh won't be charged with a crime the d.a
emphasized
that blake was not unarmed he was armed
he had a knife uh listen to this jacob
blake
while actively resisting arms himself
with a knife
i continue to hear i think i heard it
the rally last night
the vigil where someone again said he
was unarmed
it is absolutely incontrovertible that
jacob blake was armed with a knife
during this encounter
uncontroversial most uncontrovertible
because
jacob blake in all of the times he spoke
to dci
admits he possessed a knife of course as
he eludes to there the fact that blake
was armed
and can be seen armed on video and you
can hear people shouting
drop the knife and even admits he was
armed doesn't matter
it doesn't matter to the media it
doesn't matter to the activist the
washington post
after this press conference published an
article this was yesterday
still claiming that blake was shot while
unarmed
and why not you know they know that
their readership doesn't care at all
about the truth
they know that those who buy into the
conspiracy theory that racist cops are
executing black people
are immune to facts and that's why this
next part of the press conference also
made no difference to them but i'll play
it anyway because i think it's important
here's the da um playing the the initial
9-1-1 call from blake's ex-girlfriend an
alleged rape victim
and here's how that went listen michael
blake is here and he has the keys to a
rental that i purchased that i need to
take back and he's not trying to release
it
and on top of that he's not supposed to
be here today is his son's birthday so
i'll allow him
to spend a couple hours with him but
he's not giving me the keys to this
bundle and that's all i'm asking for i
never would have called you guys
i promise you i'll try to keep from
calling you guys he's crashed
numerous of my vehicles in the past and
i literally just bought one
like yesterday and so just because he
heard some false information
he's not willing to give me the keys to
this car that doesn't even belong to me
me and my sisters just saw him scared
off in it and turn around and come back
so i need you guys to comment i need
these people okay what is your name
my name is laquisha booker go ahead and
show the girls that
go ahead and tell them that she's not
put your shoes on the police are on
their way here
yes it is do not put your shoes on
israel
you didn't even want to go outside is
jacob there right now
yes and he's about he's trying to kiss
his kid so he can hurry up at least
after he he was here just talking all
types of crazy
and now he's walking off now now he's
getting ready to leave well let me get
the license plate
okay so they came because they were
called by the woman there
uh and the real victim in this case by
the way who quite reasonably wanted to
prevent her abusive ex-boyfriend who she
had a restraining order against
from stealing her car and crashing it
again she says he's done this before and
crashed it
uh this time with her kids inside the
d.a also revealed
and here was a new revelation that three
of the bullet wounds
in blake's body uh were on his side
not his back so even the part about
being shot in the back that was a lie
too
that's not true which confirms what the
officer claimed and what um
eyewitnesses reported that as the
officer grabbed him
to prevent him from climbing into his
ex-girlfriend's vehicle blake turned
back around towards the officer with the
knife still in his hand
it was at that point that the officer
fired
why did the officer grab blake in the
first place well because
he was a violent again a violent armed
criminal
tri wanted felon trying to evade arrest
by driving away in a stolen vehicle with
children inside
thing is the officers would have been
entirely justified in shooting him dead
on the spot for that
reason alone even if it was in the back
when you've got a wanted fugitive
uh a alleged rapist
abusive person restraining order against
him he's trying to get into a car
the car of his victim steal it kids
inside
drive away to get to you know you don't
know what he's going to do
is there going to be a high speed chase
is it going to hold one of the kids
hostage who knows
if your only way to stop him from
getting into the car is to shoot him
you'd be completely justified in doing
that
in fact you would be unjustified in not
doing it
if you let him get into that car with
those kids and because he didn't want to
shoot him
that would be on you as a police officer
that would be the real outrage
but on top of all that you know the fact
that he turned back towards them with
the knife in his hand only adds an
exclamation point to the officer's
innocence
but as i said there is an outrage in the
da's decision there is a miscarriage of
justice it's not what the left is
claiming
as they weep and wail over a police
officer not being charged with a crime
for shooting a violent armed felon in
self-defense
no the outrage is that jacob blake is
not being charged with any crime
keep in mind he had already been given
merely probation for the charges
stemming from the original warrant and
again
he had that warrant because he was
accused of unlawfully entering a woman's
house raping her then stealing her
credit cards and her vehicle
he was given two years of probation for
that back in november
now he faces no charges at all for his
actions on the day of the shooting even
though those actions constitute a whole
series
of additional felonies violating a
restraining order harassment theft
assault of a police officer resisting
arrest that's just the start of it
to be clear the officers committed no
crime at all
blake on the other hand has committed
dozens of violent felonies that we know
about
since the alleged rape earlier in the
year and will face
almost no legal consequence for any of
it
this is the outrage here if you want to
be angry about the da's decision be
angry about that
jacob blake should be in prison for the
rest of his life
he is the abuser the bad guy who
suffered the
physical consequences of his own actions
and now should suffer legal consequences
too
and all the while the woman his
ex-girlfriend the woman you heard in
that 9-1-1 tape
has been silenced ignored that's the
first time we've heard her voice
throughout all of this the media has
never even
asked they don't bring her up it's like
she doesn't exist
silenced ignored and forgotten
throughout this whole affair
nobody says her name no one's taking a
knee on her behalf
yet she remains the victim not jacob
blake
who is if he's a victim of anything he's
a victim of nothing but
his own choices now let's get to our
five headlines
the runoff election in georgia yesterday
uh it's looking like democrats are
poised to
win both races and take control of the
senate um
the nightmare situation has been
realized i'm i'm uh
i'm not one to panic
over election results and i'm still not
panicking now i don't think panic is
ever the appropriate response to
anything really
um but this is a very bad
situation because the democrats as we
know
with each passing day they just plunge
deeper and deeper into their own insane
radicalism
and now they're going to control the
entire government on top of that um
they're you know they're out for revenge
they feel like they need to avenge the
last four years of them not being in
control
and who knows what they're going to do
with it i mean our
our prayer now our hope is that they'll
be too incompetent and and fighting too
much amongst themselves
to do any real damage and that's that's
the hope
and uh it may be uh whether it's a
reasonable hope or not i'm not sure but
the question now is with republicans
losing
the senate uh and the state of georgia
you know who do we blame
and you could say well it doesn't matter
we don't need to play the blame game
what
what does it matter to go back it does
kind of matter if we want to
learn any lessons for the future then we
need to we need to learn
we need to we need to know what what
what went wrong why did this happen
now the narrative that's taking shape it
seems like uh among many on the right
especially especially you know trump
trump supporters uh
the narrative that i'm i'm seeing right
now is that well this is mitch
mcconnell's fault
because uh you know he didn't get the he
opposed the two thousand dollar stimulus
checks
and uh and voters are very upset about
that and that's why this happened
now i'm sure that played a part
right and uh and i was on this show
talking about
600 bucks isn't going to do anything if
you're going to send the checks i oppose
the stimulus bill the way that it was
written
they're going to send the checks needs
to be more than 600 i think 2 000 is
better than 600.
um but even with the 2000 the way they
were doing it it still would be
basically
probably useless for the most part i
but i just don't see how that is is
what's at fault here because the reality
is
this was a close election in a state the
republicans should have won
and what we know is that there were
prominent
people on the right who are either
explicitly saying
or implying for months
that voters in georgia might as well not
vote because it's just going to be
stolen and rigged anyway so there's no
reason to vote
either people on the right conserve
so-called supposed conservatives
either explicitly encouraging
republicans in georgia
not to vote or depressing the turnout
um in slightly more subtle ways
how is that not what's at fault here
when you had you had
you had people on the right depressing
their own turnout
disenfranchising their own voters
telling their own voters
not to vote and then what do you know
republicans lose and we're supposed to
blame
mitch mcconnell we're supposed to blame
somebody else
not someone like lynn wood who's out
there doing rallies in georgia telling
people not to vote for republicans
somehow he oh no it's not him come on
it's absolutely ridiculous yeah it turns
out
when you tell your voters not to vote
you lose
wow what a what a what an amazing turn
of events no it couldn't possibly be
that
when you had when you had people on the
right telling republicans not to vote
and then republicans don't vote there's
low voter turnout
and they lose no but i don't i don't see
the connection here how could you
possibly connect these dots
no it must be all about the stimulus
bill
come on no what this is is this is um
you know this is cya this is cover your
ass
there are a lot of people on the right
some prominent people who are
responsible for this
because they were out there depressing
turnout and now this is on them this is
their fault we're going to have
democrats in charge of the entire
government for at least two years
everything that happens because of that
it is on them it's their fault
and i know mitch mcconnell apologists
i'm happy to blame him
for anything he can be blamed for but i
don't think he gets to blame for this
because he wasn't the one out there
doing rallies in georgia
telling conservatives not to vote he
wasn't the one doing that
one thing is clear though um
that this had to do with republicans not
showing up lower
low turnout okay it wasn't that
republicans
voted democrat in large numbers i don't
think that was the case despite the
media narrative
bolstered by interviews with voters like
this i want to show you this here was an
interview
in georgia with a supposed lifelong
republican but
i'm i'm a little suspicious of it i
don't know you tell me
but let's let's listen to this there are
a couple of reasons why i came today
one there's a responsibility i have as a
citizen of the united states
to come out and exercise my right to
vote there's many people around the
world
that don't have this privilege so i want
to do that two
i know that the entire country is
looking at georgia right now
as to what our decision is going to be
so i needed to at least make
my voice be heard through the exercise
exercising my right to vote have been a
lifelong republican this is the first
time i've ever voted
for a democratic candidate just because
there are issues regarding our
environment
regarding taxation regarding
diversity issues and so forth that i
think need to be addressed and i'm
hoping they will be
with a senate that can actually help
encourage and enact president biden's
policies sure
lifelong georgian republican and his top
issues are
taxation the environment and diversity
right
this guy's been republican his whole
life down there in georgia and uh all
he's scared about is diversity in the
environment but he's been a lifelong
republican right
see i i i've kind of changed my view on
this a little bit because
when i first heard that i thought um
well this guy's just you know he's he's
uh just a d he's a democrat voter
pretending that he was lifelong
republican
um it could be that but when i when i
just listened to there i
i started to think maybe i think maybe
something else is going on here i think
maybe this is a this is actually a
lifelong republican
who's just lying i don't know if he
voted democrat or not but he's
certainly lying about his reasons for
doing it
because he's talking to the media and
he's trying to say
he's trying to say what he thinks the
media wants to hear
maybe it's more that i don't know but
just the way he's like
well um because he he didn't he didn't
he certainly doesn't sound like a
republican there he doesn't exactly
sound like a democrat either
he sounds like he's just bs'ing he says
you know um
i was motivated by things regarding
diversity issues you know environment
issues
uh it doesn't sound like someone
actually cares about those issues
so i'm not sure which it is could be
could be a little could be virtue
signaling
you know uh republican trying to say hey
i'm one of the cool guys
could be a democrat pretending but
whatever it is we know there's a lot of
bs being uh
being heaped on us in that video a
little bit a little bit of comic relief
though we got at least we got that
something to laugh about amid all the
dreariness number two going back to the
kenosha story for a minute um
i just saw this before we went on there
lebron james has weighed in
and speaking of someone bsing their way
along sounding like they have no idea
what they're talking about um
here's lebron james i'm smart enough to
know that even though we're playing a
game of basketball that there's so much
more that's going on in the world
so so much more that's even more
important than us playing the game
um and uh to hear what happened to
kenosha today was a
um was a blow to the heart and to the
gut um
you know not only to that community um
you know but to us
and to every um you know i guess
you know black person that that just has
uh been a part of this process
and seeing these outcomes for so long
and not only just in the black community
but also in the white community as well
who
who who see uh you know moments like
this happen to us
um to happen to his family and to happen
to the kid himself um
to see that verdict it was just um it
was a blow to the gut like i said in the
blow to the heart
but we got to continue to we got to
continue to stay strong
um continue to to believe in each other
and continue to push for
for the for the greater of change and
for the greater good and uh to hear
uh you know my people turn on in georgia
um in the fashion that they did
um i definitely want to get some more
information on it but i heard they
turned out in georgia and that's
commendable um it's something that we
started with more than a vote and we
want to continue to do that and continue
to support
you know actions like this and causes
that went on today um
has been going on obviously so i'm proud
of um you know proud of my people
for getting out there and doing what
they do best so and that's being heard
and being seen
and being powerful and being engaged
yeah this guy has no idea what's going
on he has no clue
that was just one long parade of cliches
uh i'm proud of uh down there in georgia
the the turnout and uh you know the
situations that are going on down there
there's all kinds of situations i'm
proud of those situations
there are other situations i'm not proud
of you know those bad situations are
good situations
but i just really i like the good
situations and i'm and um
um i'm just so proud of that this guy's
just no clue
no clue what's going on in the world um
and he calls jacob blake a kid
oh you know that poor kid that kid jacob
blake's like 30 years old
a wanted felon 30 years old allegedly
raped a woman
you know assaulted a police he's just
just an innocent kid and of course
lebron james we talk about how the woman
is being ignored in all this
uh lebron james that's another one he's
he's never
acknowledged her never said anything
about her
doesn't care at all but the fact that
lebron
really has no idea what's going on it
doesn't care that's the point he doesn't
really care you think he really cares
about jacob blake and what's happening
in kenosha
it's not like someone like lebron is uh
is
misguided in it it's really passionate
but he's just a [ __ ] and he's misguided
that that's the i think it's incorrect
to see it that way
i think you're doing him a favor yeah he
might be a [ __ ]
and he might be misguided in many ways
that's not exactly what's happening here
i think he doesn't really care at all
um he's living in his mansion in los
angeles
just kind of casually throwing hand
grenades
into into uh into crowded cities
doing his part to spark rioting and
looting and unrest doesn't care at all
doesn't mean anything to him he just
knows it's kind of a popular thing to
say and
it's getting him some good attention
that he likes and the right kinds of
people are
patting him on the back for it and so he
doesn't care
just kind of casually yanking the pin
out tossing the grenade
doesn't matter to him guy's a sociopath
a lot of those out there number three it
seems like we see videos like this
you know five times a week but here's
another altercation sparked by
a member of the volunteer mask gestapo
uh many people take it upon themselves
they join the mass gestapo on a
volunteer basis they they
are you know if they're on a plane or if
they're a restaurant or in a grocery
store
they're even though they don't work
there they're just patrolling looking
out for masculine people
and here's another example of a guy
without a mask being harassed
by someone for not wearing it let's
watch that
you have 70 000 twitter followers well
they're not
that means nothing you're still being
very rude
these men are just drinking coffee
[Music]
that's more effective than the mask so
why don't you step back and leave it
you're right involved
over here yes i am because your friends
have been on this train
with this mask
we're having an issue here okay correct
me if i'm wrong
but this woman she has a okay
she has a mask she has a visor does she
also have goggles
am i saying that correctly i know she's
wearing glasses but
it looks to me like this uh the mask
gestapo member there this this woman who
who i don't know if you heard that but
she uh what i really wanted to hear is
at the very beginning she bragged about
having 70 000 twitter followers
which i'm skeptical of by the way in the
first place
but she says uh she said she had 70 000
twitter followers so she was she was
taking a video of this guy sitting on
the train without
a mask on and saying i'm gonna i'm gonna
tell on you
i'm telling i'm telling they're like my
kids
a bunch of tattletails i have to tell my
kids every day especially my daughter
she's going through a tattletail phase
i have to talk to her about this every
single day and i'm working with her
precisely because i don't want her and
i'll end up like that
with a visor and goggles and a mask
taking a video of some guy
minding his own damn business on a train
drinking a
bottle of water he doesn't have his mask
on i'm telling
except my daughter seven this nut case
is 70.
my daughter has an excuse what's your
excuse
uh this is i really think that
and and we know that the lockdowns and
everything things have happened over the
last several months have
have uh caused a crisis of mental health
and we hear about that a lot
but i think we focus on you know the
plight of people who are
trapped in their homes and they're alone
they're isolated and maybe they were
already dealing with things like
depression
or or you know drug addiction and and
how
how hard this is on them and we should
be focusing on that because i think that
that's
you know those are people who are being
being forgotten in all of this
and we know that suicides are up and
everything
but when we talk about the the mental
health toll
i think also this like the woman there
in that video
there are people who have just been
broken
and many of them probably were already
broken but even more so have been
broken by things that have happened over
the last
few months and now they're leaving their
home with goggles
a visor a mask
if somebody just pulls down a mask to
take a drink of water they start
freaking out
terrified i was i was going for a jog
the other day around the neighborhood
and you could say that maybe i'm the one
with mental health problems if i'm going
for a jog
uh because even when i was doing it i
was kind of like every time i jog i
think to myself why am i doing this
exactly
what is the point of what i'm doing
right now i don't exactly know but i was
jogging around the neighborhood
and uh i passed by a guy he was out he
was
outside in his own driveway with a mask
on in his own driveway
there's nobody else around i mean i i
wrote i
i ran by him you know 20 yards away
in his own driveway with a mascot these
are people that have been
broken mentally broken
and i don't think there's any easy
recovery from it the woman in that video
eventually if we ever move past this and
uh the mask ordinances go away if that
ever happens
you think she's just gonna go back to
normal assuming she was ever normal to
begin with
no this paranoia and fear and this this
um
you know this disposition they have now
it's not going to go away
this compulsion
but um all right let's go let's go to
number four here
here's a shocking report from nbc news
this here it is get ready for this
prepare yourself it says
a new study suggests transgender women
i.e men who identify as women
maintain an athletic advantage over
their cisgender peers even after a year
on hormone therapy
the results published last month in the
british journal journal of sports
medicine
could mean the current one-year waiting
period for olympic athletes who are
transitioning
is inadequate the study's lead author dr
timothy roberts a pediatrician and the
director of the adolescent medical
training program at children's mercy
hospital in kansas
kansas city missouri said for the
olympic level the elite level i'd say
probably two years is more
realistic than one year at one year the
trans women on average still have an
advantage over the cis women
uh and then it goes on from there so
what they're saying is when a man says
he's a woman and then
goes and competes against women he still
has the biological advantage of men
even though he says he's a woman why
does he have that biological advantage
i don't know they don't go into details
in this study but i think it's probably
because
he still is a man that's probably the
reason
because it's kind of a mystery right why
would a a man who says he's a woman
and then competes against women in
sports and still has the biological
advantage
of men how could that be how is it
possible
is it that he's still biologically a man
is it that he'll always be biologically
a man no matter what he says or how he
identifies
or what drugs he takes or
or what medical procedures he undergoes
he will still
always be a biological man could that be
the case i don't know the study doesn't
say
the study instead they i don't know how
much i don't know how much they spent on
this how much money they spent
um how many years they spent on this
doing this study but in the end all they
do is confirm
what everybody with common sense knew
right away anyway
so i'm glad that they could do that
study i mean they you know i don't know
they could they could have just whatever
however
however many millions they spent on this
study they could have just given it to
me and i would have told them that
that's something to keep in mind for
next time number five finally i want to
play this for you
just because it's uh it's fascinating in
a sick kind of way it's fascinating i
think just to
witness camilla harris attempting to
pretend to be human
um you remember we we talked about
yesterday
the story camilla told about when she
was a kid and she fell out of a stroller
and shouted freedom like william wallace
well apparently she's been telling that
story
which was plagiarized from martin luther
king jr um as
it turns out she's been telling that for
years and here's uh here's
an examples that were dug up let's watch
this
well i was in a stroller and i was in a
stroller and
um so i was out there and in fact my
mother used to have a very funny story
but i was
fussing and and and she said kamala what
do you want and i said and this is how
she would say it
and she said come like what do you want
and i said freedom
oh come on it was a much cuter story
when she would tell it but that's the
story she told
by the way is that how they're doing the
late night shows now i guess that is it
that
i haven't watched i never watch them so
i really don't know but they've been
doing this the whole time it's like
skype
i guess i'm way behind the times because
i don't i don't really care that much
i've never watched them but
anyway that's her touch she told there
was another video she told the story
somewhere else on stage
it's always a little bit she adds
different a little bit of
different you know she embellishes in
different places and adds details here
and there but
uh that's that's the story and
my question is this is the thing
nobody's asking
if it really well it didn't happen okay
but let's let's pretend for a moment
that it did happen
um how could your child fall out of a
stroller
and you not notice that's what i don't
get
because number one you're you're you're
walking the child with the stroller if
they fall out they're gonna probably
fall in front of the stroller so what
you just run over the child
just like step on them and walk over
them and not even know what was that
bump uh probably nothing
that's probably someone else's kid you
keep going you go like two blocks
hey where'd the kid go
that's you know that's the least of our
concerns with that story but it is uh
it's still
if that story is true then camille
harris is revealing that she had a very
neglectful
mother so we know that at least now
quick word from our friends over at rock
otto you know
a good thing for for me ever since i
moved to uh to tennessee is that we've
been able to save
a lot of money because that's one of the
greatest one of the reasons why
everybody's moving to tennessee and if
two bit many people move then it becomes
expensive so please everyone's
well it's i think we got to cut it off
now that i've moved here everyone else
would stop moving
i should be the last one so i get to
have all the benefits for myself but
anyway
saving money um in in tennessee but it's
always good i want to save more money
okay because i'm greedy in that way
and that's why i use rockauto.com it's
so much easier and so much cheaper than
walking into a store
and you know having to deal with all
that somebody demanding quick answers to
the questions that you might have
um and uh and at the end of the day
whatever you're looking for they
probably won't have it they got to order
it online anyway
why not do that cut out the middleman
you've got access to rockauto.com
at your desk or in your pocket you carry
it around with you all the time why not
just pull out your phone go to
rockauto.com
and find anything you're looking for and
at rockauto.com they've got the lowest
prices possible
and also the best selection they've got
everything you could possibly want
and you know you're gonna you're gonna
get it at a great price and it's gonna
be easy to navigate and find
you know you don't need to be an expert
in these things i know i'm not in order
to navigate your way around the site
and uh find what you're looking for the
rockauto.com catalog is unique it's
again remarkably easy to navigate you
can quickly see all the parts available
for your vehicle you can choose the
brands the specifications
prices you prefer amazing selection
reliably low prices all the parts your
car
will ever need rockauto.com so go to
rockauto.com right now
see all the parts available for your car
truck right walsh in there how did you
hear about us box
so they know that we sent you and uh
also
listen important to tell you about this
because there's a reason that millions
of people
believe lies about conservatives and
that's because they've been trained to
do so by content creators that despise
us
we talk about bias in the media well
bias in the news media is a problem
that's not nearly as bad as the bias you
get in entertainment i think the bias
and entertainment
is a lot more influential because people
are moved by it
when they're not expecting it when you
watch the news you expect
sort of to get bias but a lot of people
when they sit down they watch
just they consume entertainment they
don't expect it
and so they're much more susceptible to
it
that's why they always say politics is
downstream from culture and we as a
culture are starving for content that's
edgy and entertaining
and also awesome but that doesn't mock
conservative values
that's why we need to give people
options and daily wire is aiming to do
just that
and that's why we've told you about the
new film the new daily wire film is our
first film we're very excited about it's
called run hide fight this is not your
stereotypical
conservative film in fact it's not it's
not political at all i wouldn't really
call it a conservative film at all
it's also not family friendly okay this
is not something you'd sit down with and
i'm not gonna sit down with my
seven-year-old kids
and watch it with them it is intense
it's violent but it has a powerful
message that goes with it as well
the movie follows a high school siege by
a quartet of school shooters
when one young girl 17 year old zoe hall
uses her wits and survival skills
to fight back uh i've seen the movie
myself
and you're talking about the 17 year old
girl the character zoe hall
uh the performance there there's one
thing that really jumped out at me
watching the movie i think it'll jump
out at you too
is um many of the performances in the
movie are very good the performance
especially of the lead
uh the league character who plays zoe
hall i thought was
was uh was really spectacular so we're
really excited to show you this film and
bring you something that's never been
done before in conservative media
run hide fight will be available to
watch on friday january 15th at
dailywire.com
and we'll be doing a special live stream
premiere the night before on thursday
january 14th on the daily wire youtube
channel
let's kick off 2021 by fighting back on
culture
and creating our own content now let's
get to our daily cancellation
so today we're canceling alistair mook
dog on fleas and the okie dokie brothers
now i never thought i'd see the day when
i had to cancel
alistair mook doggone fleas and the
okidoki brothers
mainly because i had no idea who they
were as it turns out
they are bands that perform children's
music now prior to this the only
children's band i knew of
is called the wiggles and they're a
group of insufferable
abominable australians who dress like
crew members on the starship enterprise
and sing songs about fruit salad my
oldest kids
were obsessed with the wiggles for years
and i was driven to the edge of insanity
on many long car rides
forced to listen to wiggles songs on
repeat for hours on
end it's like a violation of the geneva
convention or something
because of this experience i have
developed a deep loathing of children's
bands and perhaps that's informing my
decision today to cancel the okie dokie
brothers and the rest of the crew
i don't know but i think they they
richly deserve it that's what i think
but you tell me what you think
here's the npr report it says three of
the five
acts nominated for the 2021 best
children's album grammy award are saying
no thanks
they're upset that the contenders in
their category are all white
one of them is alistair mook whose
nominated album
be a pain is about american heroes who
stood up for their principles the
reverend martin luther king jr harvey
milk
rosa parks the parkland florida shooting
student protesters and others
harvey milk by the way was a a petrist
but you know
sure why not sing about him in your
children's album no big deal there upon
hearing the news he was uh he was
going back to the articles upon hearing
the news he was nominated that he was
nominated along with three other white
male acts and one white woman mook
smacked his head after this year to have
an all-white slate of nominees
seemed really tone deaf he says the
boston-based singer-songwriter says he'd
love to get a grammy grammy but
i don't want it like this where the
playing field's not even
mook is protesting by turning down his
nominations so our fellow acts
dog on fleas and the okie dokie brothers
okay now we have to we have to pause
here to acknowledge a certain
possibility
as i said i've never listened to any of
these bands i don't know much about
the children's music space other than
the fact that it makes me want to stick
my head into a blender
it's possible that these particular acts
never had any chance of winning in the
first place and so now they're saving
the embarrassment of losing by
pretending to decline the nomination
for noble reasons so it would be kind of
like if i somehow was invited to play
kev to play kevin durant one on one
but i declined the invitation and said
no you know i'd love to play
and i'm sure i'd probably win but
i think someone who's you know less
privileged
should play instead i just i'm really
looking out for the underprivileged
that's right
i'd love to play i would play i'd win
you know but i just don't want to do it
it's possible that something similar to
that is going on here uh
in which case i would respect the hustle
actually but but but i'm probably being
too generous
uh here's the here's part of the letter
authored by uh these
three acts they put this letter out they
sent it to the grammys
um declining their nomination and here's
part of what it said it said
quote unfortunately this year's slate of
all white nominees
only one of whom is female is not an
aberration for children's music
in the past 10 years only about 6
percent of nominated acts have been
black-led or co-led
another eight percent or so have been
non-black poc led
those are two separate categories now
okay and around 30 percent have been
female-led
these numbers will be disappointing in
any category but in a genre whose
performers are uniquely tasked with
modeling fairness kindness and inclusion
in a country where more than half of all
children are non-whites
and after a year of national reckoning
around race and gender
the numbers are unacceptable
okay why are the numbers unacceptable
that's never explained
in all these years have there been
non-white acts
more deserving of the award on their own
merits
i don't know or is skin color now a
merit in itself
that's basically what we're told every
time there's a controversy over oh
there's there's not enough
of this particular ethnicity or race
nominated for this award
what you're saying is that just just
having that skin color that ethnicity
is a merit and that alone should uh
should should warrant an award that's
what you're saying
which isn't patronizing at all of course
but the letter gets even better they
haven't debased themselves enough simply
by withdrawing and shame because they're
white
they also feel the need to apologize for
ever allowing themselves to be
considered for a nomination in the first
place
this is what they say quote we take full
responsibility for putting ourselves in
the position we're in
so it just just stops they're
apologizing for being successful
and apparently good at what they do
that's how they put themselves in that
position
it was just by being you know a
successful children's act
and being good at it so they're
apologizing for that i'm so sorry that i
was good at this
please forgive me they say quote we
chose to submit
and distribute our album to voters even
as we were aware of this category's past
history of exclusion
we thought that this year after recent
national events all the hard work of
the family music forward racial justice
collective to bring attention to issues
of diversity equity and inclusion our
genre
and changes with the academy itself
designed to reduce bias we might see a
different outcome
we didn't and the results are frankly an
embarrassment
for the field of children's music
i agree that you know they are an
embarrassment to the field of children's
music
but not for the reasons they seem to
think they're an embarrassment in
general
and they are evidence that white guilt
has become a mental
illness well let's not make the mistake
of assuming that this is all just empty
and cynical virtue signaling i mean
it is that but i believe it also
reflects a real
authentic derangement no white guilt
seems to be almost a sort of body
dysmorphia i think that's the category
it belongs
it's not naturally occurring babies
aren't born with it
it's it's a disease that is injected
into the mind instilled
it happens through conditioning but the
result is that many white people in our
country today i'm not sure how many but
too many
really do hate themselves they believe
their skin color some sort of ancestral
curse
they believe that they inherit guilt and
sin along with their skin pigmentation
and they have to purge themselves of the
evil atone make amends
reparations it's almost like it's
strikingly similar to the doctrine of
original sin
but perverted and twisted around and
racialized
i almost feel pity for the people who
suffer this mental affliction but
that pity is overwhelmed just by the
contempt i have for them
and that's why they're canceled alistair
moog dog
on fleas and the okie dokie brothers
all canceled and that'll do it for today
thanks for watching everybody thanks for
listening have a great day godspeed
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
our technical director is austin stevens
production manager pablo vadasky
the show is edited by danny d'amico our
audio is mixed by mike coromina
hair makeup is done by nika geneva and
production assistant mckenna waters
the matt wall show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021.
georgia determines control of the senate
republicans on capitol hill try to stop
certification of the presidential vote
and a shocking new report says men in
dresses still beat women at sports
check it out on the michael knowles show